oh how do ballet dancers keep fit and
supple when they're stuck at home great
question
[Music]
beautiful making the most of being
unable to get out these stars from the
Michalowski theater in Sept Petersburg
have performed what they call
self-isolation ballet instead of the
stage their routines took place in their
gardens kitchens and bathrooms their
props were knives forks plates pans pots
all the performances at the theater have
stopped during the outbreak that
inventiveness is life is be applauded by
my next guests they're also dancers
Bolivar strike strictly different type
it's AJ and Curtis Pritchard and they
have their own ideas of how to help all
of us get dancing hello boys yeah I am
fine it's good to see your smiling faces
now tell me what you've been up to you
too busy actually
we create this idea which is dress up
dance and donate so basically we were
sat on the stone for thinking what can
we do everyone is in this position roll
going a little bit stir-crazy so we need
to do something so that's thought let's
create a dance
nice easy videos so people can learn
they can get off the sofa put a smile on
the face have fun and raise money but
incredible NHS which are going over and
above yeah we just want to use our time
wisely we can see that everybody's doing
their little part however they can help
so it just made sense for us to do the
hashtag dress of fans donate and mainly
for me the hashtag dress apart because I
am the worst I will literally live in my
pajamas 24/7 so for me to get out how to
put suits on get dressed up into outfits
we did I am in saliva on Sunday Curtis
was Batman we stood down in a dinosaur
outfit my outfit didn't turn up signs
are wearing day to dress I wasn't happy
about it yeah because it was raising
money for the NHS and all their
charities and it was worth it and great
my legs were really out tell me how
people help raise money again what do
they do they well we just want them to
obviously get up off the sofa release
goodand off
and join him with us but more so
pointing the donate sign it is just go
online you can type in NHS Charities
together and that is the main charity
that helps to affect anything to copa90
whether it be a frontline staff or
equipment and that's the main charity
that would be made to make into a Virgin
Money Giving page that's the page that
you give the money to
okay so talk to me about the routines
how do people learn the routines they
learn it during the week a bit like on
Strictly I suppose they learned during
the week and then they perform with you
at the weekend tutorials super easy
dance thing so we walk through it nice
and slowly then we do an Instagram live
on the Sunday we did and for us it's
just it's just about having fun getting
people together keeping the brain mind
active because it's really slim good
endorphins we need to exercise we need
to stay physically immensely fit and the
great thing is if you've got kids as
well they love joy in it it's a form of
X and that's why the fancy dress ones is
so well because you can still be doing
it still getting dressed up still
sending us your video with the hashtag
dress up dance donate and we'll be Rico
since o so get creative and get having
fun okay have you got any dance moves
that you can show us it's just any
ability any age to join in it's so
simple and it just puts a smile on your
face I'm sure not that I can see you
here K on the other side I'm sure you
were you were getting into raptures it
weren't you I was actually yeah you're
right you're right okay so that people
who are you've obviously gone half way
through your routine this week or Reggie
they go to your Instagram can they still
take part on some day and they do they
need to donate in or before they do that
we're not going pressure on people but
obviously any anything helps even if
it's one pound and yes you can continue
watching the videos
joining with Eclipse because we're still
having fun with it definitely I think we
just love it it's just so much fun to
use our time wisely and that thing
together as well it's quite nice the
biggest things is we all need to be
standing together as a nation right now
and what everyone's doing with the
clapping we're all doing it together and
we need to be really united so this
dance we just wanted to do someone where
everyone can get involved and feel as
one really in this time of need
yeah I mean I'd be remiss not to ask you
AJ I'm sure lots of people are thinking
this and you probably don't know but
I'll ask you anyway what's gonna happen
to strictly this year I have no idea
honestly I think it will go for all of
the future ventures that I've got myself
and curs
hopefully this this passes by is gonna
be longer than we all think and the
great thing is with shows like strictly
and all the big TV shows there is so
much positivity around them and even the
thought of them shows in the future when
beasts bring star towns strictly they
bring positive thoughts to everybody so
when we watch them as a family that's
nice knowing that we've still got them
there and even if they have to stick
repeat song let's just think repeats on
all the great shows actually met school
weights just honestly all I'm doing is
watching TV all night okay quick
shoulder move again boys before I let
you go really well practice that tonight
at 8 o'clock for our carers come and see
me in the studio when everything's back
to normal this morning yeh take our boys
thank you bye that made you smile didn't
know